a native native of Brooklyn New York
William Bennett went to high school here
in the district at Gonzaga famed high
school he studied philosophy at Williams
College and took a PhD at the University
of Texas at Austin in political
philosophy and earned a law degree from
Harvard he has had a multifaceted career
centered mostly on education he was a
ward winning teacher at Boston
University at UT and at Harvard and
three times he has been confirmed
executive in the Ronald Reagan and
George V Bush administration's including
holding two cabinet level positions he
was chairman of the National Endowment
of humanities for Ronald Reagan before
he appointed him Secretary of Education
and he was the nation's first drug czar
under George Bush the elder he's also
been very successful in the private
sector he was the co-founder of k-12 and
online education company worked with
Project Lead the Way a leading provider
of training curriculum in American
schools and he's an on an adviser for
you to city.com and online higher
education company based in California
and another one called Beanstalk
innovation International Education
company but you probably are very
familiar with his writings from the book
of virtues to his justly praised three
volumes set on the history of the United
States called last the last best hope he
is the author of 24 more more than 24
books including two of which were New
York Times number one bestsellers he is
currently the host of the number seven
ranked nationally syndicated radio show
morning in America please join me in
welcoming former sect of education dr.
William J Bennett
Thank You Matthew
ladies and gentlemen sounds like more
like an obituary every year doesn't it
I guess that's I guess that's right
anyway thank you so much following these
two important men and leaders of
Hillsdale is a great pleasure and honor
these by the way are the golden days of
Hillsdale it has never been better
it's never been better let and you
should be very proud to be associated
with it I know something of Hillsdale
sent me of the history I won't do a
Ronald Reagan joke Oh 1844 yes I
remember that yeah but I've have known
about it for a while and these are
indeed the golden days well done
well that nicely done guys I'm gonna be
brief or at least not as long as it may
seem to Soviet and then we'll do some
Q&A whatever you want to talk about I'm
gonna talk about the Constitution in a
somewhat different way a couple of
examples of where we're falling short I
think and the Constitution as part of
the culture and why the culture is
hurting the cause of the Constitution
I'm not going to respond to John you
that's a heck of an act to follow I'll
tell you did you all then anybody make
reference to John you on the Jon Stewart
Show anybody ever see that John you was
on the Jon Stewart Show yeah that Jon
Stewart and John Stewart decided to take
him on foolish man
and the next day John Stewart said and
this is available on YouTube he said I
got my lunch handed to me last night
bye-bye John you it was devastating that
was brilliant and it was all perfectly
deserved a couple things about the
Constitution you may or may not know
some of this you will know some of this
you may not
did you know that our Constitution is
the most imitated political document in
the world that's pretty good
even regimes that are not legitimate
site and quote our Constitution to
appear legitimate it is the market is
the currency of political legitimacy
we have lived longer though we are a
young country we have lived longer
continuously under a single document
than any people in the world despite the
fact that we are a young country there's
a joke a story about the man who goes
into the British Museum which is of
course the library in London and asked
for a copy of the French Constitution
I'm sorry sir says the clerk we don't
keep periodicals here this one has
lasted the American Revolution has
lasted as well because it is one of the
few in history that has not betrayed the
hopes of its children it continues to
offer those hopes and that solace
what is Constitution or what is
constitutionalism someone said once I
love that I love this it's the hope and
belief that words on parchment can keep
men to their duties and responsibilities
think about that really is what it is
isn't it the notion that those words can
keep us to our responsibilities yeah we
can talk and maybe we have to go to war
maybe we have to go to court but those
words will somehow guide us and bind us
why is the Constitution suffering today
first of all in some quarters of our
country more and more people are turning
to it adhering to it carrying it around
referring to it saying let's go back to
it many others are ignoring it I'll talk
about one of those guys in a minute one
of the reasons for this I believe in a
phrase is the pollution of time things
old are now considered bad because they
are old things new are considered good
only because they are new I used to
teach in classrooms when I became
Secretary of Education United States my
wife said why don't you go into
classrooms around the country and talk
to kids and then make your
pronouncements about education so why
don't you do your homework first
I said why should I be different from
the other guys in Washington she said
because you are the Secretary of
Education to your homework I said Lena I
am the Secretary of Education I don't do
retail I do wholesale and she the
daughter of a successful businessman
said do good retail and you'll do better
wholesale so I went to the Emma Kahn
Elementary School in Raleigh North
Carolina taught the third grade and I
asked him whether it was a good thing or
bad thing to grow old and they were all
convinced it was a bad thing to grow old
why because you get cranky and rickety
and you forget things and you step on
your glasses some truth to that
so I said well let me tell you a story
about a guy who was getting old guy
named George Washington and I told the
story you know it well famous story
about how Washington was trying to stop
his troops from marching marching on
Washington after the war that hadn't
been paid and they wanted to get paid
they were ready to come down and hold
Congress at Bayonet Point maybe not the
worst idea in the history of older
respect for some of your colleagues you
know that Washington was making his
arguments he wasn't particularly
eloquent and he remembered something
someone had written down he'd put it in
his pocket he pulled it out when he
pulled it out he put on his spectacles
and he heard a gasp from his men because
they had never seen him in eyeglasses
before and he said ah I see you're
surprised to see that I wear spectacles
he said well I have become not only gray
but almost blind in the service of my
country that simple eloquence reminded
them of who he was who they were what
they were engaged in and so they
abandoned their plan
I said now part of his convincing kids
was because he was old getting older it
wasn't it they said yeah well maybe
maybe not all bad
this philosophers trick I'm a teacher of
philosophy it's a distinction between
the natural good and the moral good you
might get older and more rickety and
clumsy and fall down a few times but you
can still get better in a moral sense
they have nothing to do with how you are
as a natural creature but as a moral
creature things can get better but
that's not where the emphasis is on the
culture the culture today emphasizes the
new and the young and the innovative in
education a field I know pretty well
about 30 years ago innovative became a
synonym for good traditional became a
synonym for bad it's also suffering the
cause of constitutionalism because our
culture's disbelief in limiting
principles and clear and objective
truths our president has abused these
kinds of
additional powers at almost every turn
from delaying and changing the
implementation of Obamacare in how many
different ways to enacting immigration
reforms by executive Fiat but pulling
short of enacting the ones we thought he
was going to do this time to making
unconstitutional recess appointments to
the NLRB there are a lot of examples
when I sight all the time is it just
rings so untrue to what our founders
were talking about was Congress passing
a law to insulate themselves from the
costs of Obamacare to get a subvention
from the government agencies so they
could cover all their costs even if they
were increased dramatically in a way
that the American people would not be
covered James Madison wrote in
Federalist 57 they will make no law of
the legislature which will not have its
full operation upon themselves and their
friends as well as on the great mass of
the society that's a great betrayal what
they did there and it's not the only one
the public's ignorant of the
Constitution allows for this and the
public's indifference to it allows for
it and the public's disappointment and
cynicism about Palpa Senate
disappointment in and cynicism about
politics also contributes to this
disregard of the Constitution but the
public's not aware of a lot of things
and when Larry talks about crisis the
crisis that most concerns me is the
crisis of understanding of crisis so
failure to grasp to understand what this
country is and what it is about can be
illustrated in lots of ways was
illustrated in 2012 in a Pew Research
poll reporting that 49 percent of people
aged 18 to 29 49 % of people aged 18 to
29 say they have a positive view of
socialism 43% say they have a negative
view the Pew poll found that 46% of
people aged 18 to 29 have a positive
view of capitalism 40% of negative views
for the 18 to 29 year olds socialism is
better than capitalism what the hell
have we been doing what in God's name
have we been teaching let's go back to
college let's go back to Hillsdale let's
go back to the high schools let's get
this thing right you want regard for the
Constitution let's get the history right
in 1987 yesterday 1987 I was in 7
September 17th 1987 I was in Nicaragua
and Managua I was asked to give a speech
I was Ronald Reagan's Secretary of
Education was asked to give a speech
about our Constitution and of course the
war was raging between the countries and
the Sandinistas I gave the speech
afterwards I was congratulated from the
speech by some of the Contra people and
the mothers and that I group came up
black robes and it was well teachers or
at least the same order
Jesuits my friend dr. Ryan will know
we're talking about here
they said pretty good you're pretty good
these were left-wing Jesuits is that
redundant saying yeah you you've got
you've got some you can simply taught
you how to speak but you have the
message wrong I said no I don't think so
and I talked about freedom and talked
about the hopes of freedom of for those
people I'll never forget that I'll never
forget that trip the plane stopped in
Tegucigalpa we got some more gas we
landed in Managua planes slowed down I
don't think it ever really fully stopped
and we were told to get out we look to
our left and there were Cuban soldiers
there were Russian planes the man their
clothes and it was a great opportunity
to give that speech that night I stayed
at the
American Embassy called my wife she said
what's that in the background I said
fireworks fireworks it was fire but it
wasn't fireworks anyway
the regard we have for the Constitution
is sacred but it is underappreciated
that document because of the reasons I
have just cited the country has never
needed it more because the country has
never needed guardrails more let me tell
you what I think is going on by
borrowing from one of my favorite
authors I know favorite author of many
of you - and that's CS Lewis I'll
conclude my remarks with some of his
thoughts why don't people pay more
attention to the Constitution well Louis
would put it this way at least I think
he would approve of putting it this way
this is the great book Screwtape Letters
this is the advice of one devil to
another you remember this this is Uncle
Screwtape - nephew
wormwood he writes we must encourage in
them the horror of the same old thing
the horror of the same old thing is one
of the most valuable possessions we have
produced in the human heart there's an
endless source for us of catching souls
it is a source of heresy and religion
following counsel infidelity in marriage
and in constancy and friendship humans
live in time and they experience reality
successively to experience much of it
therefore they must experience many
different things in other words they
must experience change and since they
need change the enemy it's of course God
has made change pleasurable to them but
since he does not wish them to make
change any more than eating an end in
itself
he has balanced the love and change in
them by a love of permanence as well we
must destroy that love of permanence and
replace it instead
with only a love of change of a proposed
course of action he the enemy wants men
so far as I can see to ask very simple
questions is it right is it prudent is
it possible but if we can keep men from
asking those questions and ask instead
is it in accordance with the general
movement of our time is it progressive
is it reactionary will I be a
contemporary will I be well regarded in
my neighborhood is this the way that
history's going then they will neglect
the relevant questions again what are
those relevant questions is it right is
it righteous is it prudent is it
possible all change is good according to
screw tape all permanence is bad
we need the Constitution because we need
that permanence we need that
Constitution because we need those
guardrails but almost the entire culture
is in war that war against the permanent
it likes the new it doesn't like the old
it likes the innovative it doesn't like
the tradition the innovative can be good
but it's a separate category of analysis
it isn't good simply because it's new
simply because it is the iPhone 6 or
plus does it make it good that just
makes it new but if you want to produce
a frenzy do not produce a constitution
unless maybe there's a constitution 6
plus produce a new piece of technology
if we are to be kept from merely
pursuing the frenzy and pursuing the
ephemeral we need to have regard for the
time that it takes to do good and
important work
the kind of work that is done patiently
and thoughtfully over the years at a
hell's Dale College the time work that
is taken in a home by a family with its
children
the time and the work that ought to be
taken in a school in those years from K
to 12 which have become such a wasteland
in so many places the monster bull by so
many facts because we live in a world in
which people are not sure there is
something called truth how can they have
repair to the truth of our polity the
truth of our republic which is our
constitutional the problem lies in us
crisis to use Larry sword lies on us the
crisis lies in the culture and I believe
that's where the solution lies to so
let's enter the culture at all those
places let's talk as he says let's teach
let's remember what we learned and teach
them to the next generation Wordsworth
says what we have loved others will love
but we must teach them how they don't
know this when they're born we have to
teach them that's our work thank you
very much I welcome your questions
you